I went to welcome to this video playing
chrome off cool awesome yeah from the
Queens gambit ooh I actually placed this
this thing area I had a number of games
against him already with this opening we
often got in turn into a caster
structure at this time that should be
for being played yeah just developed
normally it takes surprising okay that's
the idea yes okay I'm not particularly
happy about it but probably have to it's
still not that should big deal
yep just normal move to develop my pen
only three is really not very nice I'm
probably very long okay and water anyway
definitely need some water yeah how is
it going to play tonight to see several
maybe something like that nope so I'm
going to try for night to see fire
annoying annoying a little bit
one idea is to bring in the night to d3
possibly to F form so with my deaf one
finally getting little spin yeah so 94
so here this position is roughly equal
the key idea for black hair is to put a
night on to d6 it doesn't seem like he's
trying to accomplish that what is he
doing f5
[Music]
it doesn't feel very dangerous maybe I
should have played a form why did not
play for him yeah I could have done that
one move earlier that was pretty stupid
I mean the way he plays that he is not
defending against the minority attack
anyway that was real decision I'm just I
just gave away ever move for nothing
basically yeah at one point you have to
do it I mean that doesn't work but he
has to play it to get some kind of play
okay so night wants to go to have five i
guess if i take here a knighthood go
anyway I put it here take just H for
stopping any whatever g5
what's the point what's the point nine
f5 or just going to double on the pole
w on c6
yes so if i take 136 you will take on g4
one no the thing is this possibly night
takes each for ipad2 this night XD for
and then you will grab them ok so maybe
Queen d3 after all night takes h4 I can
also play book c6 I don't have to take
it right away and I th for politics that
that also is not working really not I
don't think so but is much simpler after
night XH what just takes six
but I can take them no reason not to
we also have to watch the big black rank
and three takes at five is also an idea
in some cases
[Music]
you
9555 is hanging I think I can just take
it don't really see why not ok ji wook
t7 rupee one maybe let's attack the
Queen yeah maybe I just take here this
is probably the easiest way to do it got
so many palms ok I like waving yeah that
was that was the cleanest way I think to
do it yeah I think like if like it's
completely fine you of course but what
he did not do it and I think he did not
play the normal way of doing it he is a
the Black Knight belongs to d6 a good
way he has to maybe try this and once
the night lives on the six black is
perfectly fine I mean I'd rather be
black problem but it later he played
this at five portion and this mostly we
can let loss supposed to be adapted a
for of course I lost the full temple now
and now the minority attack arrives and
he just stuck with weaknesses and really
tried this f4 desperation but there is
nothing going on I can just take stuff
now ok again and that was quite
reasonable I think yet there is one
opportunity renamed
the whole opening was nothing for me but
here I am that is a data plan is not not
the best this is really good you know
something that says like this night
comes to d6 for example if I play like
here something like that that is leading
nowhere I cannot go be five the night is
defending all this so black it's fine
you can still play this ideas but with
the 96 each month it's much more
promising because you stopped everything
that white half I think I probably would
try something like this and something
like that which is which is just equal I
guess with the opening of the position
roughly equal I think this is easier for
YT equal life and just stay in the
console the structure with the 996 like
a sweet it comfortable ok guys thanks
for watching